[MUSIC PLAYING]
AYELET OZ: What I'm going
to talk to you about today
is the lot going on in criminal
justice in Israel these days.
It's actually very
exciting times
to be a lawyer, which is always.
And we kind of
rethink a lot of what
we used to think about
punishments and about prisons,
and it's a trend that started
around the world except the US,
which we'll talk
about in a second,
and starting to
move on to Israel.
And actually we're in
really exciting times.
So I want to first take you back
about a decade ago, like 2009.
And a decade ago, it seemed
as if Israel is just following
the footsteps of the US.
And what happened in
the US more or less
since the 1970s
is what we usually
call the incarceration crisis
or the mass incarceration
of the US.
There's been a huge
leap in the number
of Americans incarcerated.
Lots of them are black.
Actually, one of the figures
is that if you are, I think 25
and black in the
US, you have more
of a chance to be
in prison than you
have to graduate from college.
So this is a lot
about race in the US
and a lot about how the US
deals with criminal justice
and with crime rates.
And it seems as if Israel
is following this--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AYELET OZ: The
question is what's
the difference between
a jail and prison.
So jail is mostly for
shorter prison sentences.
A lot of times, it would
be in the state jail,
and prison is for
longer sentences.
And what you can actually
also learn from this graph
is that the prison
sentence, there's not only
more people in prison, but
prison sentences are also
longer, meaning people get
sent to longer years in prison
in America now.
And just like to give you
kind of an international
perspective, this is how
removed the US is in terms
of its incarceration rate.
Meaning this is like
most of Europe and such,
and the US is just
off the charts.
This is Israel.
I'm really sorry that
the graphs are in Hebrew.
It's from PDFs.
So I'll explain
what it's saying.
Israel is in red
in both of them.
So what we see here
is first that we
have a lot of use of
prison sentence in regard
to other sentences.
So it's about 0.42
in prison in regard
to fines and other
punishments, and 177 people out
of every 10,000 in prison.
And again, if we return to
the US, you remember the 698.
So we are not there yet,
but we are still very high
up in comparison
to other countries.
And this is like, if
we talk in numbers,
we see it as a slight decrease,
actually, in people in prison
in Israel in just like the
last two or three years,
but it's mostly stable.
I would say just so you
got your numbers right
that these are only criminal
prisoners in Israel.
There are also
about 6,000 of what
we call security
prisoners, which
are people who are incarcerated
for security felonies,
and there are about 600 migrants
who are in migration detention.
This number used to be
higher, but now it's
somewhat along the 600.
Talking about security
prisoners is a large topic
and we'll not discuss it now,
mostly because what we're
talking about is
criminal justice policy
and how we relate to crime,
and security prisoners, usually
the number rises and
falls more in regards
to the security situation than
what we are talking about.
But I just wanted you
to have the numbers.
And as you can see, even
if we compare Israel
to similar countries
like in terms
of size of the
population and such,
these are mostly the
Nordic countries,
which we'll return to
later on, because Finland
is a very interesting story.
You can see we are
much higher than that,
and this is the figure
that I've lost before,
which is how much we
use prison in comparison
to other sentences.
And the number is, I think
today, it's closer to 40%.
And the question is, OK,
so you tell me, OK, we
need to fight crime somehow and
the way we need to fight crime
is by putting people in prison.
But the thing is, Israel
doesn't have that much crime.
So you know, if we compare
it to other countries who
have like a mediocre amount
of crime, and not only that,
the crime rate is
not only decreasing,
actually falling down
in the last decade.
This is the crime rate
in the last decade,
and it's a constant trend.
It's actually a trend
that happens elsewhere
in the world, meaning
crime rates are going down,
mostly in the developed world,
and in Israel in specific.
And it does not match
the rise in prison.
So you cannot say, well, we
use prison more so the crime is
declining.
So this is not the case.
OK, so why do we use punishment?
So now I want to kind of like
go back from the graphs and such
and try to show you,
OK, so why do we
use the prison sentence that
much if we don't have the crime
rate.
And the answer is there's no
need to do that, basically.
So up until the '90s,
more or less, like the way
all criminal justice
specialists thought
was, well, OK, let's
put this in an equation.
So we put the chances of
someone to get caught,
and the punishment he's
going to get, multiply
the one by the other, and this
is what will make him decide,
do I want to commit
this crime or not.
So if, for example, I enjoy
robbing the elderly very much,
I will say, OK, I have about
a 50% chance of getting caught
and I will spend two
years in prison if I do.
So I have this one year
calculated prison sentence,
but you know, I actually enjoy
robbing the elderly a year
and a half.
So OK, I'll do it.
It's worthwhile.
You know, like our basic
101 economic thought.
The problem is that when you put
this to test, none of the data
actually supports this.
One of the things that was
most studied in criminology
is this question, does
increasing the punishment
create deterrence.
And if there's one thing
criminologists would agree on,
the answer is no.
If you've tried to
think, OK, why, then no.
So first I tell you
that it's not correct
because of the studies
that were done.
There were studies
that were created,
like they had all these
experiments, you know,
and you add the punishment
and nothing changes.
And they had like
natural experiments
in which the punishment
rose, but still there
was no effect on crime.
And then, well, you try to think
about it, but why, you know.
Let's take our nice
elderly robber.
He got his math right, right.
And there's actually a few
quite intuitive explanations
to why this doesn't work.
First is that people--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does
this hold even when
you increase the
punishment drastically,
like capital punishment
for every minor felony?
Will this still hold?
AYELET OZ: This actually is
the extreme that does work.
So for example, when you have
like some natural experiments
in which, let's say the legal
system collapsed totally,
so no punishment for
nothing, you do see a rise,
but this happens
only at the margins.
Meaning if you either kill
everybody or have no law
at all, you will see an effect.
But let's say, well, you
know, your every day new bill,
OK someone robbed
the elderly, let's
put 10 years on elderly robbery,
this virtually makes no change.
So one thing is because
people mind more
the chances of getting
caught versus the punishment.
So if you do raise the
chances of getting caught,
meaning you put more
officers out there,
you do see a change
in deterrence.
So for example,
I'll give myself.
I used to drive my bike
on the sideways to work,
and then they
started giving fines
to people right on the sidewalk,
and I stopped doing that.
Actually stopped driving,
now I walk to work.
And this would help, meaning
increased enforcement
does help, but if they
would leave the enforcement
as is and would
only say, no, you
don't get a 500 shekel fine,
you will get a 1000 shekel fine,
this would not help.
This would not change
the behavior of people.
One reason is because
people underestimate
their chances of getting
caught, so they would say,
OK, well, you know,
they'll put me
a life sentence for
driving on a sidewalk,
but they'll never
catch me so who cares.
Another main reason is--
I saw you laughing when I gave
you our nice elderly robber,
and the reason
that you laughed is
that no one, no criminal,
or actually most criminals,
do not do this calculation.
People perform felonies,
mostly street felonies,
meaning violence,
break through and such,
because of a variety of reasons,
and rational decision making
is the least of.
It's because they're
addicted to drugs or alcohol,
or because they got caught
up in being very excited,
so they made a felony.
It's a variety of reasons,
and people do not calculate.
And actually, when
they did studies
in which they ask people, what
did you think of when you did,
I don't know, the
murder or something,
like the vast majority
of people do not even
think about the punishment
that they're going to get.
It's just not something that
is calculated when you actually
perform felonies.
Another reason is
because, well, if I'm
going to ask you now, what
is the punishment for armed
robbery, like I don't know.
AUDIENCE: 10 years.
AYELET OZ: 10 years?
And I'm going to rephrase,
how much do people actually
get for armed robbery, like
not what's within the law.
The law says, I
think, about 10 years.
AUDIENCE: Five years.
AYELET OZ: Five years.
Three years.
OK, so as you can see, we
can throw hands around.
People actually don't
know what the punishment
for armed robbery is.
I'm actually a criminal
justice lawyer, and in order
to see what the punishment--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AYELET OZ: Yes,
so actually, OK, I
need to get my case law
right, you know, the trends.
People don't actually know.
There is some kind of like
common understanding, which
is many times wrong about
how much people get,
and most necessarily when
the law is changed, you know,
because again there was this
guy who robbed the elderly
and now we're going to
double the sentence,
there's no reason that
potential criminals would
know what the punishment is.
So this is another
reason why it does not
affect their decision making.
And they'll never
catch me, is actually
something we discovered.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
not necessarily true
because a lot of people
who perform armed robbery
are part of street
gangs, and they know what
sentences their friends get.
AYELET OZ: Let's take
the street gangs.
Even if they do
know, and generally
like organized crime
and such, the idea
is that they become
a member of a gang,
not because they enjoy,
usually, armed robbery,
but because of the social
tension that [INAUDIBLE] them,
because the organization pays
for them and for the families,
meaning that the total
reasons that lead them
to those armed
robberies and such
is far more complex than what
is the punishment for it.
Actually, what the
punishment for it
is somewhere so low in the
decision making mechanism,
so to use this as our main
tool for fighting crime
is actually not
effective, most of all.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Question, is there
a difference between offenses
where there is a big difference
between the punishment as
described by the law and
the actual punishment,
which is trends by
case law rather than
where the case law follows
strictly or almost completely
with the legislated punishment?
AYELET OZ: Actually, in
the vast majority of cases
there's a huge difference
between what's ascribed in law
and what is actually
given, and it's actually
part of the system.
The sentences are
maximum sentences
except for when there
are mandatory minimums.
Mandatory minimums are still
heavily used in the US,
and they are a
considerable reason
for what we saw in the
incarceration crisis.
And there are a lot of problems
with mandatory minimums,
but in this case, in
like this spectrum,
they do raise the
certainty of punishment,
but they have like a lot of
problems that would make us not
want to use them.
Like one thing, they
promote guilty pleas.
So if I can, you know,
plea something else,
even if I didn't do it, only to
escape the mandatory minimum,
I will do it, because
if I do go to court,
I might get the
mandatory minimum,
and there are a lot
of other problems
with mandatory
minimums, but they
do solve this specific problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there
mandatory minimums in Israel.
AYELET OZ: There are.
There are a few, actually,
like back a decade ago,
there was this huge trend.
Like everything got
mandatory minimums.
But actually,
there's case law that
says that you can put the
mandatory minimum on like,
to be served only if
he does another crime,
or as civil work.
So there are all kinds of ways
that case law kind of like
tried to move the
mandatory minimums around.
So they are not as
harsh as in the US,
and actually, nowadays the
trend kind of went down,
I think a lot because of
the problem of guilty pleas,
and because they saw that
mandatory minimums kind
of distort the system and
the play between the parties.
So now they don't
use it that much,
although they could come back.
Like it's a running
trend, we can call it.
But then, OK, a bit to what
this guy was saying, OK
so what happened.
OK, but we can't
stop sending people
to prison because the crime
rates will go off the roof.
And here, we actually have
the really interesting example
of Finland.
And like just to put
Finland in perspective,
this is more or less the
incarceration rate in Europe.
So we have over here the
former Soviet Union, which
uses incarceration quite a bit.
This is Eastern
Europe, Western Europe,
and these are the
Nordic countries.
As you can see,
as we always say,
the Nordic counties
are really nice.
They don't use prison a lot.
They just hug over there
all the time, you know.
It's a really lovely
place to live.
So as you can see, all
the Nordic countries
use prison in quite a low rate.
And they use a lot of
alternatives to incarceration.
They actually have a
really nice system.
But Finland was not as nice
as it went up until '90s.
So you could see, if we zoom
in on the Nordic countries,
you could see that Finland
had in comparison quite
a large incarceration rate.
So if they had somewhere
around 60 people per 1000,
Finland had nearly 200
per 1,000 population,
and then it had this
big prison reform,
and went down and became as nice
as the other Nordic countries.
And you would expect, OK, if
we reduce by 2/3 our prison
population, OK, the crime
must go off the roof,
right And what we
see is actually,
there is an increase
in the crime
rate in the Nordic countries
ever since the '50s to now,
but what we can see, Finland is
somewhere here in the middle,
it does not jump up
more than everyone else.
Like, it reduced its
prison population by 2/3,
but the rise in crime
was similar to all
the other countries
who never had those.
So you can see, I think
it's a very strong example
to show that there really
is no logical connection
between the use of the prison
sentence and the crime rate.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
number of prisoners [INAUDIBLE]
population and the
other is percentage
of crime of sentences
that are imprisonment
because in one case
for this metric,
you have an effect of
prior incarceration,
but people who were
incarcerated in, I don't know,
1940s or something, they
could get out of prison,
but since people are not
put in prison anymore,
I think it's two
different metrics.
AYELET OZ: OK, these are
two different metrics.
What can you study
from this to this?
Like these are two
different metrics.
They don't need to combine.
And I do agree these are
two different metrics.
What I'm saying is that
you would expect the crime
rate in Finland to behave very
differently than the crime
rate in the other countries.
So because they had this really
major reform, and what you see
is not that change.
This is what I'm trying to
make out of these graphs, not
more than that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about Singapore?
I understand that in there
the punishment is severe
and the crime is really down.
AYELET OZ: I must
admit I don't know,
so I don't want to
just make up things,
but what we do see many
times and we're not
going to get there, that the
reasons for why there isn't
or there is no
crime are actually
much wider than the
criminal justice system.
So for example, if you
have a welfare state,
the crime rates are lower, and
it's because of the welfare.
It's not because of how much
people they put in prison.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering about
this measure of crime rates.
Imagine that you, with your
scooter riding on the sidewalk,
it would not be counted there,
unless you were caught, maybe,
and then you have to
pay the fine and so on.
But people are riding on
the sidewalk all the time,
and I doubt that
most of them are here
in Israel's crime rate.
AYELET OZ: There is a somewhat
stable rate of how much people
report certain crimes.
So for some crimes, we have
virtually 100% report rate,
homicides, things that
have to do with insurance.
For example, if your
apartment got broken into,
because you need the insurance
it's virtually close to 100%.
We have other areas in which
there's a very low report rate.
For example, if your bikes
get stolen, in most times,
actually going to the
police would do nothing.
And unless you actually
want it for your insurance,
you won't do it.
There's a big
question, for example,
about sex felonies,
how much is there
versus how much is reported.
But for all of these, the
report rate is pretty stable.
So for example, if this
goes up or this goes down
will not tell us how much crime
there really is in a country.
It differs.
Like the report rate
differs between countries.
The more you trust the
police, you'll report more.
But it does tell
you, does it go up
or does it go down,
because there's no reason
to believe that the report rate
had changed so dramatically,
especially not in this country.
Like there wasn't
a big, like down
rate or up rate in how much
you believe the police.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Let's say that car
theft is highly reported.
Since the 1950s, there is
also more cars in society.
AYELET OZ: Yeah, but again, once
you put everything together.
So yeah, kinds of
crime do change.
But in the meaning
of the overall trend,
it gives you, even if you can't
say, oh, well we have 10,000,
and you know, really put
some essence in this number,
the trends do give
you the picture.
There were other?
OK.
And now I want to stop
talking about international
comparisons, and now
I want to give you
a bit of who are the
people in prison in Israel.
Like when you think of people
in prison, what you usually
think about are
the sex felonies,
you think about, our
nice armed robber, you
think about homicide.
But the vast
majority of prisoners
are actually in very
short prison sentences.
So as you can see--
I thought I had
the numbers, but I
think the common number is
that about 75% of prisoners
are up to two years in
prison, and everybody else
are in the long tail.
So when we talk about
the use of prison,
we usually imagine those
very serious felonies,
but the people who are
actually going into prison
are most of the time for
medium range felonies.
So if it's a really
low felony, you
will usually not go to prison.
But kind of like
the medium range
is the vast majority of people
in prison who just change.
So one problem with
the prison sentence
is that it has what we call the
criminogenic effect, meaning
if there's one thing that will
determine if someone will go
to prison again, yes or not, is
the question, was he in prison
before.
People who were in prison
to a vastly larger ratio
go back to prison, and
there are a few explanations
to why this is
happening, one of which
is that people are getting
accustomed to prison,
meaning once you've been
to prison for, let's say,
six months, you're not as scared
of it as people who come out.
We actually have this really
big problem with minors,
meaning a minor who was
arrested, for the first three
days, let's say two weeks,
he will do everything
to go out of prison.
He will agree to go to
rehabilitation plans.
He will agree to take all
kind of restrictions and such.
But after he's been like a
month and a half in prison,
oh, you know, you get
accustomed to stuff.
And prison, actually, you
know, you could live in there.
No one is asking
you to do anything,
you've got your friends,
and OK, well, I'm
not going to go to rehab now.
Rehab is hard.
And it's actually a great
problem with minors, but also
with adults.
People get accustomed to
prison, and in prison they
get a network of other
people who are criminals,
and many times they
get disconnected
from the previous environment,
from the previous community,
and this is the only
community they know.
They have a really
hard time going back
to society in regards
to work, to employment,
to finding an apartment.
So all of these
things actually do
what we call the rotating door.
They put people back to
prison basically because they
have nothing else to look for
outside once they're going out
of prison.
So we do have a really
important mission
to try to prevent those
short time sentences,
because I think we can all agree
that if someone, I don't know,
raped a woman, he
should be in prison.
Actually, like in most
cases, it won't be debatable.
AUDIENCE: So what crimes
are we talking about?
AYELET OZ: We're talking about
breaking into apartments,
like in small numbers.
We're talking about
drug felonies.
We're talking about battery and
assault in a really low key.
We're talking about
slightly larger theft.
So this is like really
low violence act
or mediocre property felonies,
basically, and drug felonies.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't like just
the fact of getting convicted
enough to put you
into this cycle,
even without going to prison?
AYELET OZ: No, not
to the same extent.
I mean, yes, and we'll
talk about alternatives
to the criminal process.
There is some problem
when you get convicted.
So it has some of these effects,
but the effects of taking you
out of the community, of
isolating you, and making you
like recreate your
sense of identity,
this happens to a
large extent in prison
and will not happen if you
still live with your family,
if you still go to work
and all these things.
So the concept of
isolating you is
one of the harsher
effects of prison.
Like this is the huge
amount of the punishment,
and it's also the one
thing that has the most
effect on what happens next.
So actually, yeah, so
I'm going to go back
to the money in a second.
So there was actually this
very important committee,
you said, in 2015, led by the
Supreme Justice Dalia Dorner.
And this why it's called
the Dorner report.
And it actually tried to
rethink criminal justice
policy in Israel, and unlike
most of these committees,
this actually like
really got implemented
in government decision.
Now they are following
reports on how
everything should change.
But it really had
its wave, and it's
something that is very real
in criminal justice today.
It's not something like,
OK, let's take our report,
put it in a nice
drawer and carry on
with our lives, which is usually
happening with such reports.
So the Dorner report had a few
very important suggestions.
One is, as we started
talking about,
what you think about
what happens in prisons,
and what works and what doesn't,
and data is sometimes very
different, is to try to create
data based criminal justice
policy.
So you know, if you're
a member of Parliament
and you want to propose
a bill to increase
the punishment for something,
first get your data right.
Would it help, what are
the specific attributes
of this population, all of these
things, how much would it cost.
So first, now everybody
following the Dorner report,
every bill in regards to
criminal justice policy
needs to have like this little
research on how it's actually
going to affect,
and not what you
think because you
read it in the papers.
Another thing is
extending the community
courts, which we'll
come to in a second,
to increase the use of
early release and parole.
Early release, what
we call [NON-ENGLISH],,
like when you go home after
2/3 of your prison sentence,
the rates of using parole is
actually radically decreased
in Israel.
It used to be about like 65%
of people would get parole,
and now we're talking about
around 25% of prisoners.
And the problem is
that people tend
to see parole as some
kind of a reward,
like OK, you've
behaved nice in prison.
We'll let you go early.
But I don't think it's
actually the right way
to think of parole, because what
we do when you do parole is,
you get this, I don't know,
a few months or sometimes
a few years in
which you still have
large leverage against a person.
Like OK, you're
going to go to rehab,
or you're going to go to prison.
So you can actually help a
person go back to society
like hand in hand and
one step at a time.
So OK, let's get you back
together with your family,
or if this is hard,
let's let put you
in a rehabilitation center.
OK, let's do this.
Why don't you go to work,
OK, and we'll follow,
and we'll help you
go back to work.
So when you finally finish your
prison sentence and parole,
you can actually go back,
and the revolving door
will not be standing right
there in front of you,
because OK, you've done
it one step at a time.
While if you don't get a
parole, it's just like,
you know, at some point
your prison sentence ends,
and you just go out
and there's nothing.
There is no support group.
You have nowhere to work.
You have nowhere
to live many times.
And you know, you just like
crash into the revolving door,
basically.
And I think one of the things
the Dorner report had said
is that we need to rethink
our use of early release.
It's not a reward.
It's something that we do
in order to protect society,
basically.
In order to reduce the number of
early or very short time prison
sentences, they did say,
OK, let's allow more time
for community work.
Now in Israel community work
is limited to six months,
and there was a bill that
changed it to nine months.
So OK, some of these
people can work
more time so we can avoid
those short prison sentences,
and the open prisons which
we'll talk about in a second.
And the one thing
that I wanted to add
was, OK, you know,
where's the money.
How much does it cost, all
this prison, and the thing
is it's really costly.
It's a lot of money to
put people in prison.
So if you put people in
prison, this is the first row,
it's about 120,000 shekels
a year per prisoner.
And if you take care
of it in the community,
meaning a hostel or
parole officer, et cetera,
it's somewhere
between 5,000 to let's
say 50,000 shekels per year.
AUDIENCE: These numbers,
10,000 shekels per month?
AYELET OZ: Per month,
yeah, from the prison
organization, from Shabas.
Like these are the
prisons' numbers.
This is what they
base their budget on.
AUDIENCE: They
probably have to--
I mean, even if you lower
the number of prisoners,
don't we still have
to pay some costs for,
you know, the number
of guards might
be, like not lower the same
way and for the facilities,
we still have to pay for them.
So I'm not sure,
[INAUDIBLE] overhead
in which you can't reduce if you
reduce the number of prisoners.
AYELET OZ: I think it depends
on how much you reduce, right?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I don't think
to myself, like 10,000 shekels
just for food, for
transportation.
AYELET OZ: Yeah, but you don't
need guards guarding you 24/7.
You don't need education.
You don't need a counselor.
You don't need special people
to drive you from one place
to another that includes guards.
The cost of keeping a prisoner
safe, and going to the doctor
and going to his court
sessions, and not fighting
with the other
prisoners, and making
sure he does not commit suicide,
sometimes are very pricey.
For example, in a
maximum security prison,
those rates would go really up.
Like making sure, for
example, an ex-officer
does not get killed in
prison, that costs a lot.
For others, it would be cheaper.
AUDIENCE: If I release
someone, then immediately I--
AYELET OZ: It's not
easy, but it depends.
Like you know, if you released
let's say 1,000 people,
you might be able to--
AUDIENCE: You might
be able to close the--
AYELET OZ: Yeah, you may
do, and that would save.
And actually if you look, if
you look at the numbers, though,
actually like if you
compare from 2010,
there was really a
substantial drop.
Like we're talking 2,000 people.
This is about three prisons.
This is a lot of money.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
graph before?
AYELET OZ: Which
one, the before.
AUDIENCE: We just talked about,
so we talk for 2010 until now,
so what happened before?
Like it was on the rise and
then started falling down, or?
AYELET OZ: It's
complicated, basically.
Like there were a lot of trends.
Now if we talk about like prison
history from the 1950s to now,
that's going to require
a longer talk, basically.
AUDIENCE: Of the 423
[INAUDIBLE],, does it include,
we have the education programs,
or just the maintenance
[INAUDIBLE]?
AYELET OZ: This is
basically the salary
of the parole officer divided
by the number of people
he can treat.
So this is like if the guy's
going to the community,
meaning he lives at his own
home and the parole officer
basically like manages him,
so that's the lower number.
And this is if he
is in a hostel.
So this is why I said like we'll
take it from 5,000 to 50,000.
So there is like some
prisoners, you know.
Well, basically, they
can live at home.
They can work.
You just need to make sure
they don't do anything wrong,
and that would be
the cheaper one.
And some of them will need to
go to a drug rehabilitation
center, which are
very expensive.
But still, even in
the expensive side,
it's still much lower than
a prison sentence amount.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
aggregated numbers.
Have you done segmentation
by age and by crime type?
AYELET OZ: Crime time?
AUDIENCE: Crime type.
My hypothesis is that it
would be very beneficial.
Again, I'm just
shooting off my hip.
It would be very beneficial
for like youngers.
If you decide not to send
to prison people below 18,
and then try to find them
some sort of army service,
like we can use the army as
a rehabilitation service.
Because it's like--
AYELET OZ: It does
actually happen.
It's a major figure.
AUDIENCE: My hypothesis
is that if someone starts
getting to jail when
he's young, he's
going to stay in
jail all his life.
So the going back, going
back and forth, this
is the reason I've always
seen, like they always
talk about the
African Americans,
is that there's problems
there, because in the US,
because it's not an ideal
place, and some places,
some people discriminate
people because they've
got [INAUDIBLE].
The young African American get
easily into jail at 14, 15,
and then they became exposed
to all the criminals,
and they become criminals.
So I would say like, it
seems like [INAUDIBLE]
for young people and
for guys that are like,
I'd say on the border between
non intentional crimes,
or I don't know.
AYELET OZ: All right,
so first regarding
juvenile criminal
justice, there's
a huge difference between
Israel and the US,
and it used to be like
this for all the time.
In the US, basically,
for harsher felonies,
they treat juveniles
as if they were adults,
and they send them to
unthinkable times in prison.
In Israel, this is not the case.
In order to be a juvenile
and get into prison,
meaning into the Ofek prison,
which is the juvenile prison,
you need to drop out of several,
a long list of places before.
The entire system
tries, and I'm saying it
like as a public defender,
tries its best in order not
to send young and
juvenile people to prison.
The amount, I think now in Ofek,
there are about 150 juveniles,
and these are all the juveniles
from the entire country.
There is a substantial
attempt in order
to try to rehabilitate
juveniles.
So I'm putting juveniles out.
They do go to prison only in
like the hardest, hardest,
hardest cases.
And in this way, Ofek in a way
is the most difficult prison
in Israel.
Like the average adult
prisoner would be much easier
than the average
juvenile in Ofek.
So I'm putting juveniles aside.
And as we said, the group
that we're talking about,
we're not talking about the
killers and the rapists.
We're talking about this
huge amount of, as we said,
it's not that they're
unintentional crimes.
For unintentional crimes,
unless you killed someone,
you will not go to prison.
But if it's your first time,
or let's say, you know,
it's not your first time, but
it's kind of like something
that has to do with your
drug addiction, you could go,
like go back to seven months
in prison over and over again.
But besides us paying you to
go to prison for seven months,
it won't help in any way.
So we need to rethink it,
not because, you know,
you deserve it, but
because it would be cheaper
and it would be more
effective to think
about it in other ways, because
just putting you to live seven
or nine months in
prison would just
do no good, except you are going
down, coming down, coming in,
coming out.
And it could actually
happen a lot of times.
So now we have 10 more
minutes to kind of give you
some of these new ideas, new
ways of thinking that we now
have in order to think, OK,
so we have this young drug
addict who comes in
and out of prison,
and we're trying to rethink
what to do with him.
And now I'm going to
answer the question,
then we're going to see
this beautiful video,
the community courts.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
terms and cost.
So solve the terms and
cost, you could just
have mandatory capital
punishment every penalty.
You solve everything.
AYELET OZ: A, it will
not solve everything
because it's immoral to
kill people for everything.
AUDIENCE: That's
another problem.
AYELET OZ: OK, I'm adding
basic humanity in here.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AYELET OZ: OK, so I'm going to
propose your idea of vicious
like a dictatorship to my boss
and we'll see what happens.
But basically, there is no--
Unless you go and kill everybody
for like stealing stuff,
what you're going
to do is put them
in prison for a long time,
which will not be helpful.
AUDIENCE: And if I may, so
think about for example Saudi
Arabia, where they
chop off thieves' hands
and they behead their
rapists and drug dealers,
crime doesn't stop there.
It still continues, it seems.
They're still chopping
heads and arms.
AYELET OZ: I'm not
quite sure actually.
OK, so one thing I want to
show you, and how may I say it,
I'm sorry for this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AYELET OZ: What we figure--
OK, we'll let them
sing for a second.
- [SINGING IN HEBREW]
AYELET OZ: The amazing
singer here, she's the judge.
And the people singing with
her are the prosecutor,
the defender and
the defendants--
[END PLAYBACK]
AYELET OZ: --in the
community court.
So as you can see--
AUDIENCE: You might want to
repeat that because that music
was really high.
AYELET OZ: Yeah, so
what I said was that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AYELET OZ: Yeah, this
is how they're elected,
and their ability to
use the camera, right.
This is another main feature.
So the woman with the big
belt and the white shirt
in the middle was the judge.
On either side were the
prosecutor and the defendant
and the defense attorney.
And as you can see, they're
singing, not very good.
And what happens
in the community
courts, which now
there are three,
and there are going to be six
by the end of the year, is OK,
we take our drug addict who
comes in and out of jail,
and we figure out, OK,
coming in and out of jail
does not help us.
That's what we said before.
So the community
courts, they're trying
to use the authority
of the criminal process
and the authority of
the judge in order
to help people to
get all the help
they need in order
to be rehabilitated.
And they can be
rehabilitated from addiction.
They can have a lot
of other issues.
That can be lonely.
They can have a lot of
debt they can't handle.
So once you go to
the community court,
which it's a regular court.
It's in the court system.
There's one in [INAUDIBLE],, one
in Tel Aviv, one in Beersheba.
And so if you agree
to go in this,
you get into a
really long process.
It's usually somewhere
between a year and two years,
very intensive, in which you
get all the support you want.
So you have someone taking
care that you'd go to rehab,
someone helping you
find employment,
someone helping
you with the kids
if you don't have
anywhere to put them,
someone helping you with parents
guidance, whatever you need.
So every person in
the community courts
gets what he or she needs,
and there's actually
a really big group of
different professionals
there to help them
do what they need.
And as long as they're
in this process
and do what they need
to do with all the help
they get, in the end the
case will be overturned
or they get like no punishment
at all, something of this sort.
So actually what they do
is they use the stress
that this caused out of the
criminal process and the fear,
and the fear that you might
go to prison, and all of this
in order to gently push you into
a community that supports you
and helps you try
to figure out what's
the main problems you have.
So another name for
the community court
is problem solving courts.
So the idea is
that the people who
go there like break the
law because there are
other underlying problems,
like the criminal involvement
is only the peak of
the iceberg and we
need to go down, figure,
OK, why was she or he doing
what he did, and there's
actually a very good success
rate.
It's about two years old,
the project, so they're
only the first
people coming out,
and for now the recidivism
rate is really low.
The people say they
trust the system,
that they trust the government
and the regime much more,
and people are actually
managing to regain
control over their lives
using the community court.
So this is one thing that is
happening, is now actually
increasing, so they will
be in each of the districts
by the end of 2019, I think.
Yeah, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Who's pushing this?
AYELET OZ: Who came up with the
idea is actually a young doctor
called Daniella Beinisch.
She studied the problem
solving courts in the US
and finished her PhD.
She joined with Ashalim Joint,
which is a part of Joint,
and they joined in and
convinced the court
system and the
prosecution and everyone
to come along and try it.
AUDIENCE: So I guess my question
was, it went through the courts
system, or?
AYELET OZ: She is
an actual judge.
Like she judges other cases.
It's in the court.
It's part of the court.
It's a regular court.
And if you fail
out, you know, you
will be given a sentence
according to what you did.
AUDIENCE: I understand.
Again, my question was,
was this something that
came from elected
officials, or from judges?
AYELET OZ: The idea came
with Daniella from the US.
She came here and she actually
convinced everybody else.
AUDIENCE: Who was
the decision maker?
AYELET OZ: In the end, I
think it was the court system.
Like they needed to say,
OK, we're going to do.
But you know, if the
prosecution would say,
well, I'm going to go to this
sing along, it'll never happen.
Like the really amazing
thing is that she
managed to put everyone
around the table and say,
OK, we're going to try this.
And at first, like people
looked at her like,
I don't know, this
hippie from the US,
what's she talking about.
But now, actually, like
it's something that
has really gained confidence.
People really believe in
this and it's quite amazing
to go there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
You said in the
beginning of the talk
that there's no correlation
between jail time and the crime
rates.
But you said there
is correlation
between the chances
of me getting caught
and the crime rates.
So if we increase the number
of police officers and so on,
that will reduce
the crime, right?
AYELET OZ: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering,
why don't we just
shorten all the jail
times, or instead of like
what you just described,
the community courts, it
sounds really warm
and fuzzy, but if we
took that budget
and instead of that,
we had more police
officers out there,
wouldn't that do
much better results?
AYELET OZ: Firstly,
I do agree totally
that if we lower the
budget of the prison system
and put the money in police,
that would reduce the crime
rate more, meaning we first
need, like a lot of crime
would go down if we
increase enforcement.
So this is correct.
I don't think that
it would actually
solve these kind of cases.
The cases that come to
the community court cases
are mostly of repeating
crime that again,
comes from underlying problems.
The people, you know,
that have no money to feed
their kids would
steal even if they
know they get caught because
they just have no other option.
If he's a drug addict,
he will go and steal
because he feels he
has no other way to go.
So in these cases,
which are actually
a large number of the reasons
that lead people to crime,
the only way to actually
try and make a difference
is to try to solve the
underlying problem.
If not, like you can
put them, you know,
you will have less crime because
they will be in prison more,
but in many of the
cases, deterrence
itself will not
cause them to stop
because they see no other way.
AUDIENCE: Do you feel
that the punishments today
for light crimes are
too long or too short?
AYELET OZ: A, I think they
send too many people to prison.
Like if you're in
prison, for me,
it doesn't that matter that much
if you're there for six months
or for 12 months.
It's not the length.
It's the effect of
putting you to prison.
It has so much effect,
so much bad effects,
that this is what
I want to stop.
And I think this is more
important than the question,
like do you put someone to
three years or to five years.
I mean, for this person, I
guess it's really important,
but when we look at it
as a policy question,
I think this is what we
need to put our finger on.
The open prison is
actually another thing
that is just starting.
It's really used
a lot in Europe,
which we said one of the
main problems of prison
as we know it is
that they isolate you
from your community, from
your work, from everything.
So what they're creating
now, and there's actually
one going to be
created in Israel,
it's building up right
now, is open prisons.
So the idea is that, OK,
you need to serve your time,
so you need to have some
restrictions on your liberty,
but you don't necessarily need
to be isolated from everything.
So what an open prison is,
it's usually, as you can see,
here it's from from the UK.
It's a nice little
neighborhood basically,
and sometimes it will be
a building within a city
or two buildings within a
city, that people are there.
They need to be there
in certain hours.
They need like their
entire daily agenda
is set up for them.
Like 4:00 in the morning,
you go, you have breakfast,
you go to work, then you go
to therapy, then I don't know,
you may have an hour off,
and then you come back
and you sleep at the prison.
But the idea is that
you can maintain
some of your connections
to the community,
again, so when you
finish your prison time,
you have somewhere to go.
So OK, you have your workplace.
You've continued to
work the entire time.
The idea is to try
to find a punishment
that in some ways restricts
your liberty, and you know,
none of us would want to go
and live in an open prison.
It is punishment.
But it does not have
all the bad influences
that prison time has.
And you say, well,
they can run away.
The idea is that many
prisoners go out and come back
and they go to vacations.
Prisoners don't run that
much as you might think.
Like you know the
teaspoon that you're
carving your way to freedom,
that doesn't happen.
Like most of the prisoners go
out to vacations, they go back.
They know the price for not
coming back is enormous,
and they figure
out, well, you know,
I'd rather spend my prison time
and not sit another few years
for an attempt to run away.
And this is what the
open prisons are about.
So yeah, people might run
away, but actually the chances
are not very big, and the people
who go there to begin with
are people with medium crimes.
They're not very dangerous.
So it actually works very well.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like more
people with financial problems
will want to go in then
people would want to go out.
AYELET OZ: Yeah,
well, as I said,
I'm not quite sure any of us
would say, yeah, I know, my--
AUDIENCE: If you remember
Mr. Micawber from David
Copperfield, I
think he sort of did
that in the debtors' prison.
AYELET OZ: Another thing
that is happening right now
and is pushing, let's say
pushing people out of prison,
basically, in a
matter of policy,
is A, the overcrowding
decision of the Supreme Court.
Just last year,
Justice Rubinstein
set a case law that said that
prisons are way overcrowded
and it's unconstitutional,
so the state by April 2019
needs to reduce its
prison population in order
to fit the
overcrowding decision.
So this is one reason why
everybody's in a hurry
to reduce the prison system.
And another important case
law to know that kind of
helps this is an old case law
from 2009, which abolished
prison privatization in Israel.
One of the reasons that
costs, high rise in the US,
was private prisons, and once
the option of private prisons
was actually blocked in Israel
in 2009, it actually, in a way,
stopped the amount in
which the prisons can rise,
because it's really expensive
to build a public prison.
So just like, you
know, there are also
these decisions
that kind of help,
that kind of support all the
criminal justice reforms.
AUDIENCE: So let's give a chance
to people from [INAUDIBLE]
to ask some questions.
AUDIENCE: So the graph showing
that the population in prison
is declining, do we attribute
that to the Dorner community
changes, or something else?
AYELET OZ: It's actually not
due to the Dorner report,
because we saw the
decline a bit earlier,
and also the implementation
of the Dorner
report in like everyday cases
is just in its beginning.
It's actually a good question.
Why we see one major reason
is because the crime rates
are going down.
Actually, the number of cases
are going down in Israel
quite dramatically, so there
are just fewer prisoners
because there are fewer cases.
It's more about that than
about the Dorner report.
AUDIENCE: Do we know why?
AYELET OZ: Well, A, because
the crime rates are dropping.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, why?
AYELET OZ: Why is
a good question.
There's not actually
a straight answer
because it's also a global
trend of lower crime rates.
It has to do with the
population getting a bit richer,
meaning a lot of macro
explanations, none of them
that we can be sure of.
It's actually a
really good question
why the crime
rates are dropping,
because it's also
dropping worldwide.
So trying to explain it with
one policy decision or other
is probably wrong.
We just know it happens.
No one quite knows for sure
why it's dropping, but it is.
AUDIENCE: OK, then a
different question.
AYELET OZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You used
to have a blog.
I was a big fan of it.
You stopped updating the blog.
What happened?
AYELET OZ: Actually, I
forgot to pay my hosting
and they deleted it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Very sad.
AYELET OZ: It was very sad.
Actually, I also got
[INAUDIBLE] blog deleted
because I forgot to pay
his hosting as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: OK, so this
discussion takes into account
that criminal rehabilitation
possibilities and everything.
But I didn't hear
anything about society,
which it expects of our justice
and especially the victims.
I didn't hear the
word victim even once.
What about their
need for justice
and their need for
personal safety?
If the grandma who
was robbed sees
the one who robbed her getting
out or not even getting
into prison, I mean, you
can tell her all that,
but in many cases, she
won't want believe it.
She won't trust the law
enforcement system anymore
and might not report.
AYELET OZ: I'll try and
answer, because the question
of victims' rights movement
is actually a large question.
I will say a few things.
First, I think that the
most important places
for the victims'
rights movements
are actually in the
more severe sentences.
It's not about the
short sentences,
because as we say, in severe
violence, in the armed robbery,
people would sit a long,
four or five years.
In sex offenses, people
would sit a long time.
And I think our need
to address the victims
is most important
in these cases,
in the cases in which
the crime created
substantial trauma,
sometimes substantial risk
or substantial harm
to the victims.
And I think that in
many cases, actually,
criminal law reform and victims'
rights would go hand in hand.
For example, I would say
that the government needs
to compensate victims' rights.
For example, what's
happening now
is that usually the
offender is said,
OK, you need to compensate
the victim with the total,
like the maximum for today is
256,000 shekels, and you know,
if it's, let's say a rape
case, they would put it,
OK, you need to pay 256,000
shekels, and he goes to prison
and he's broke, and
the victim is never
going to see this money.
I mean, even if you turn
the rapist upside down
and shake him, there will
be no money out of it
because he has no money.
And I think in a way,
putting the victim vis-a-vis
the offender is a way the
government can walk away from,
and I think we
need to compensate
by the government the victims.
AUDIENCE: The victim
doesn't want the money.
The victims want to see
the criminal suffer.
AYELET OZ: Let me answer.
No, this is
AUDIENCE: That's why
we punish people.
AYELET OZ: NO.
Another thing.
No.
AUDIENCE: They want retaliation.
That's the original--
AYELET OZ: No.
Yeah, but the thing is that
studies and discussions
with victims showed that
victims are many people
and victims want many things.
Some victims want to
see the offender suffer.
They want them never
to go out of prison.
There are some victims.
Other victims do what we call
I forgot the English term,
but the idea is that
they meet their offender,
and what they want is their
offender to say, I'm sorry.
And what they want is some
kind of acknowledgment
of what was done to them.
And there are actually
these arenas in which
offender and victim can meet.
It's done in therapy and
so on, so it's not like,
oh, go meet them somewhere.
And the offender says, I now
acknowledge what I did to you,
and I am sorry, and I will
try to make it better.
And we have a lot of victims
saying, this meant more to me.
And we actually have
this, it's a kind
of a well known story of
this woman who was actually
beaten very hard,
and then like, I
think she had like a
head injury or something,
something really serious.
And she goes and she meets this
young man who did this to her,
and she actually understands
how for him, it actually
changed his entire life.
He got like 15 years in
prison or something like that.
And she goes and she meets him,
and he sees what he did to her
and acknowledges
what he did to her.
And she actually like kind
of keeps in touch with him
while he's in prison,
and this gives him
a sense of meaning that
he somehow managed,
not to make right but to
acknowledge what he did,
and she feels that she
has some kind of meaning.
And this sense of meaning,
and actually yes, money, money
to pay for therapy, money
to pay for a lot of things
that many time victims want.
And some of the victims
want nothing to do.
They don't want to hear it.
They just want to move
on with their lives,
and actually, when
you actually talk
to victims or with
advocates of victims,
you see victims
want lots of things.
And there was
actually a few cases
in which like, you know,
the prosecution says, well,
you need to send him to a
long time in prison because
of the victim.
And the victim says, I don't
care if he goes to prison.
I just want to move
on with my life.
So trying to speak in
the name of victims
and assume what victims want is
something I really don't like.
I think that we need to listen
to victims and what they want,
and I think that in
many times, actually
the defendant's rights and
victim's rights would go hand
in hand, because in a
way, they are the two
humans in the system, and
many times, looking at them
and what they need
and what they think
would make them make
different decisions than what
the system would decide.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Criminal punishment
would still be there, and it
would serve in the future,
if he comes back and
do the same thing
for some reason, the
only thing that changes
is the actual punishment.
It's not the conviction itself.
AYELET OZ: But also, as
I said, victims' rights
are mostly relevant to the
really harsher crimes, which
are actually a different
talk than the shorter prison
sentence that usually
have no victim.
For example, like in a drug
offense, there is no victim.
It's wrong, and we've put
people in prison for it,
but there is no victim.
No one is actually hurt.
SPEAKER 1: So thank
you you very much.
Actually, it was quite
fascinating for me to see.
I didn't think
about it in advance
that Googlers are engineers,
and they think numbers.
And we had many project
managers who will automatically
say, how do we optimize
the system, what
are the flaws here.
It was very interesting to me.
So thank you very much.